you know i uh
i remember there being
there being this statement that said
that google
was the first
psychedelically informed superpower
with its high-tech
vision of super connectivity and super
conductivity it was a psychedelic vision
literalized and
expressed in technical proficiency so
again google represented a psychedelic
mind state literalized it was the first
psychedelically informed
superpower
because of course it has the resources
to impact civilization and yet it's
reson d'etre is informed by psychedelic
visions of
expansion and interconnection
and
whatnot
and so in the same way that we have now
in our contemporary age psychedelically
informed superpowers
we also i believe increasingly have
psychedelically informed tourism
psychedelically informed travel
psychedelically informed
well
you know
the hotel industry right a
psychedelically informed hospitality you
might say with brands like the sixth
senses places like tulum festivals like
burning man pilgrimage like the camino
de santiago all of them are invitations
into pilgrimage invitations into a kind
a particular kind of travel one that
looks to fill not just one's
appetite but also fill one's soul right
so travel becomes no longer what you
might call mass tourism which is to
entertain ourselves to death but instead
travel becomes psychedelically informed
answering a different set of needs uh on
maslow's hierarchy of needs so these
places and spaces like the tulums of the
world like the burning mans like the
sixth senses resort the wellness spaces
where breath work and yoga and green
juice and again a psychedelically
informed sensibility informs all aspects
of the experience from the architecture
to the design to the the mood scaping
and the mood sculpting all of it is
deployed to address particular
particular preoccupations of the psyche
it is it is a journal inviting you into
writing an entry it is a question
looking for an answer everything is
designed to prompt you into reflection
to prompt you into contemplation to
prompt you into realization to prompt
you into revelation and again in the
same way that we're seeing high
technology
and and and you know that we're seeing
high technology being informed by
psychedelic sensibilities so too other
aspects of the world are having these
bleed through effects and and and the
eye and psychedelically informed
sensibilities are seeping through into
our cultural constructions everything
from tourism to travel to hospitality to
i think that the places where we deploy
our hard earned resources we want to now
spend our money on revelation capitalism
has been psychedelically informed and is
now designed to appeal to us to appeal
to the psychedelic consumer to invest in
his own self-cultivation and so the
billion dollar industry emerging is the
industry of self-cultivation informed by
psychedelic ideals like contemplation
and introspection and expansiveness and
compassion and well-being and and
sustainability and just a heightened
sensibility and an acute openness to the
to the bigger questions of existence and
to the degree that we can address these
needs that we are increasingly asking by
co-opting the forces of capital in order
to create a entire economy that serves
the needs of this new psychedelically
informed meta consciousness or this new
psychedelically informed mainstream well
we see again the world changing in the
world shifting and hopefully the world
up leveling to asking better questions
and living better answers you know
because diseases of despair that
currently afflict our world the wealth
that exists in the world cannot meet the
needs of the psyche when you have more
people killing themselves and are dying
from natural disasters and armed
conflict combined we realize the
diseases of despair cannot be resolved
by eating more food in the buffet but
instead we must
seek out endless horizons places and
spaces designed to cater to our
psychedelically informed sensibility and
the set of needs that are looking to
address the brokenness in our psyche and
the more i'm seeing this and the places
in space is like tulum like burning man
like bali
like
sixth senses resort like habitats hotels
i mean again we are seeing the the the
the
the birth of a new kind of economy
serving a new kind of need and it's
really interesting because again it
allows us to co-opt the forces of
capital to promote healing and
sustainability and renewal and
transformation and heightened
sensibility and openness and compassion
and to make seekers of us all and free
the brave reckless gods within us all
and that's why i'm an optimist and
that's why you don't
beat the system by fighting against it
but rather you change it from within
friends you change it from within
and
yeah
so i remain optimistic that we can do
this continue to up level
and in the same way that um
companies like apple
are psychedelically informed
representing the promethean dream of
eating the apple from the tree of
knowledge and stealing fire from the
gods and google being a psychedelically
informed superpower and increasingly
mass consumption being catered
towards psychedelic sensibilities i mean
i don't know i just i see the trend and
it makes me smile there's a lot of
potential
let's not thwart this opportunity let us
take full advantage of it let us
take ourselves to the stars
cheers